If a person is using the RIFE machine for Lyme disease, why do they react so severely
and what should they do to prevent Herc's reactions?
So a Herc cyber reaction is a reaction because you are reacting to the die-off of a bacteria.
So with gram-negative bacteria like Borrelia burgodorophy, it has lipopolysaccharides in the cell
membrane of that bacteria, and then when you kill it, it liberates those lipopolysaccharides
and lipopolysaccharides can damage the blood barrier across the blood barrier and cause
inflammation of the brain.
If you already have primed microglial cells, you will experience all sorts of reactions
and symptoms that have been come to note as a Herc cyber reaction.
So what could you do about it?
You have to just go slower with your treatment.
So slower with your treatment means either you run less time on the program or you move
the bulb farther away from you so there will be less effect on your body.
So I have had some Lyme patients actually have to put the machine in the bulb in the adjacent
room because they react so severely.
But typically, if you put it in the other side of the room, then if you cover it with
the pillow of the bulb, of course it's going to go through the pillow, but it's going
to disperse some farther away from the bulb, the less treatment effect it will have on
your body.
So the thing is that we recommend.